In the decades since the world became
dependent on oil and gas,
we’ve been through cycle after cycle
of boom and bust, of crisis and recovery.
In the 1970s, the 90s and now in 2022,
with Russia’s war against Ukraine,
we find ourselves once again in the grip
of soaring fossil fuel prices
that have exposed so many countries
to deep social and economic strife.
Instead of the usual cycle of crisis
and then return to a fragile status quo,
this can and must be the last time
that we are left so vulnerable.
Let me tell you why.
In the last year,
we've reached unprecedented clarity
about the fact that there is no room
for new fossil fuel infrastructure
if we are to have a decent shot
of limiting the warming
of our climate to 1.5 degrees.
These warnings have sounded against
a terrifying backdrop of climate chaos:
Europe’s rivers running dry,
apocalyptic flooding in Pakistan,
savage wildfires,
heat and drought across the world.
The devastation wrought
by our warming climate
driven by the burning of oil, gas and coal
can no longer be ignored.
At the same time,
a new reality, also driven
by our dependency on fossil fuels,
has been playing out in some
of the richest countries in the world.
In the UK, millions of people
are coming face to face
with the desperate reality
behind the term "fuel poverty."
We've had stories about pensioners
riding public buses all day to stay warm,
of local councils opening warm banks
for people who can't afford
to heat their homes.
Before the UK government announced
that it was going to freeze
the unit price of energy
in what is considered to be the single
most expensive policy announcement
since the Second World War,
40 percent of people living in the UK
were expected to be in fuel poverty
by the end of this year.
Even with that price freeze,
6.7 million households
will struggle to pay their energy bills.
How did we get here?
Why is the situation so acute?
The answer is gas.
The UK is exceptionally reliant on gas.
The vast majority of our homes
are gas-heated,
and a big chunk of our electricity
is generated by gas-fired power stations.
With that comes extreme vulnerability
to international gas prices
that are now projected to stay
unusually high until at least 2025.
In the UK and indeed across Europe,
this is a moment of huge peril.
And of huge opportunity.
As a climate change lawyer and campaigner
working in the UK
and across the global North,
conversations around fossil fuels
in the recent past,
including about our domestic significant
oil and gas industry here in the UK,
those conversations have until recently
been about the impacts of climate change
that are wreaking havoc
in other parts of the world,
or about impacts that are portrayed
as fleeting in the UK.
It's been very easy for politicians
and a media focused
on short-term news cycles to dismiss.
But that has now changed forever.
The only way to address
our energy affordability crisis
is to address its root cause,
and that is our dependency
on fossil fuels.
That's now common cause,
not just across the climate movement,
but across sectors working
on inequality and poverty as well.
Renewable energy sources,
which are our only path
away from climate catastrophe,
sources like solar and wind,
those are now nine times cheaper than gas
as a source of electricity in the UK.
Moreover, we know
that we can significantly reduce
our energy demand here
by upgrading our homes,
which are among the coldest
and leakiest in Europe.
While politicians and the fossil fuel
industry's proxies might in this moment,
and indeed are in this moment,
trying to double down
on fossil fuel production
as a solution to our
sky-high energy bills,
they are about to find out in short order
that in a moment
of acute crisis like this,
when millions of people
are experiencing the impact
in such a material and tangible way,
there is no room for peddling false hope.
There is nowhere to hide.
And while oil and gas companies
continue to record record profits
off the same forces that are driving
families all over the UK into despair,
it will become even more clear,
incontrovertibly clear,
that boom times
for the oil and gas industry
are bad times for the rest of us.
Across the UK, there are new movements
emerging to make sure
that we are never put
in this position again.
From campaigns like Warm This Winter
to Enough is Enough,
to movements to stop the opening up
of new oil and gas fields,
like Stop Rosebank,
to litigation and targeted advocacy,
there is a wave of action coming
to make sure that this is the last cycle.
This is the last time.
This can and must be
the last alarm bell to sound
about the true cost
of our reliance on fossil fuels
before we step into a more safe,
more just future for us all.
Thank you.
(Applause)